the thing I was basically trying to say
was a lot of what I communicated with
certain actors or producers that a lot
of them had a tough tough journey to get
to where they are some actors let it go
and let it go off their shoulders and
try to not handle the situations that
they were in previously not dead a
superstar or whatever but a lot like
producers or writers that gone through
some stuff or had them you know they
bring that baggage with him it's tough
it's it's a tough situation either try
to work with them because you know oh I
did it this way in 1998 and it's 2011
you're successful now let it go
but yet about basically saying was just
the whole baggage situation especially
for me being you know a young actor
trying to make it out here it's tough
trying to get into that circle when you
know you got a deal with their little
stuff too it's very irritating but that
was when I was just thinking about I'm
sorry well there's a lot of debate on
does a good artist have to have endured
a lot of struggle I think somebody can
be brilliant and maybe they grew up in a
great middle-class home and had two
parents that were wonderful there are
successful stories that come out that
way but what I've heard especially from
a lot of successful actors when they
talk about it do you have to be all
about yourself selfish all about what
I'm gonna do and how to become this
superstar
I pray that it's not like that well I
should say I pray that like that I mean
I I hope it's not like that but then
again you never know
do you think there's a way to quote I'm
quoting a seventy's book look out for
number one
mm-hmm without being a bad person yeah
you can do that you can definitely do
that yeah you can definitely do that
because I know a couple people who are
who've made themselves into successful
artists that are all about family and
friends and that's tough when you're you
know you're always especially at that
level you're always getting yanked on by
somebody hey can you help me out with
this what you want to do that and that's
pretty cool to keep everybody and like
in check was basically all right we're
all successful just because I am now you
know it's a tough it's a tough one a
deal especially if you have like family
members or friends that are just not
very shaky from the start but yeah I
believe that can't happen I'm hopefully
I know if it happens for me I'll have a
team of people that you know that will
take care of business
you